How do we minimize the repeat data in our model?
We can accomplish this goal by keeping transactions and
descriptions of transactions in separate tables connected by relationships.
In this example, rather than having one big unit table,
we could divide it into three separate tables.
Now that the data is in separate tables,
we can take out all of the repeat descriptive data,
like all the duplicate rows,
let's say Fuji and Gala,
or all of the rows that have duplicate dates and remove it.
But now we run into a new problem.
If we look at one of our sales,
we have the amount sold and the cost.
But how do we know what type of product was sold,
or for that matter,
how do we know what month or year the product was sold in?
We need some way of linking the data in these tables.
We can do this by having a unique value that is shared between the tables.
To identify the product,
we can add the unique PLU column to
both the sales table and the descriptive produce table.
Since the PLU is now in both of these tables,
it allows us to create a relationship connecting the descriptive and aggregatable data.
This is called a key.
A key is a column of unique values that is shared between tables.
With the PLU as key,
we can now see that these two transactions which have
the same PLU of 4132 were both Gala apples.
Similarly, if we want to be able to get information about the transactions,
we can add the date column to our sales table.
This serves as a unique key as well and allows us to connect with the date table.
So now, for example,
we can easily find out that all of these transactions took place in February.